hey welcome to the first episode of
project calm season two
so we've been away for a while from
youtube this winter we took a break
recharged ourselves and made a plan for
this year
so it's currently spring time here in
portugal weather has been super nice
the flowers are growing the trees are
sprouting
and overall i would say it's been nice
much less rain than we had last year
and this means also our mimosa forest
has been growing hard which is an
invasive tree so this probably all needs
to go at some point and be replaced by
native species
but luckily this means also all the
trees and bushes we planted are not
little sticks anymore but they slowly
start to flower so this would become a
tasty pear tree at some point
if it's gonna survive another year
like i said it rained a bit less as you
can see here the rivers are much lower
which is not necessarily a problem for
us because we're a bit more in the
mountains and we have water coming from
the well but slowly the neighbors start
to worry a bit more about if there would
be enough water this summer
and in general the neighbors and the
local village is just still doing their
thing steadily
dogs are still chilling around
[Music]
and our own base camp is still there
running as usual
small difference we had a few leaks here
and there which we are fixing now
and we actually did a bunch of things
this winter
let me show you what that is all is
so first thing is we assemble the team
to make sure we are here with more
people throughout the year so we're with
five people
first we have rita who's doing more the
managing of the things adrian he's more
construction and working julie she's
more of an all-rounder and likes a lot
to talk with the local people
and me i'm still here but i don't really
have a job anymore because we have a
video maker
so let me actually tell you a bit more
about this video maker and how it went
[Music]
so yeah we found a video maker and we
did this because last year we sent out
an application online asking for a video
maker to come and help us
and the main task would be produce these
weekly videos you're watching now so the
person should really be living here for
a few months and film it a person
dedicated would really improve the
quality and free up some of my own space
to do other things
and we had money available for this job
and the money actually came from the
income generated by youtube last year
so thanks to you guys watching we
actually earned 10 000 euros
so we put that online if a video maker
comes you get 10 000 euro
and we had a bunch of people signing up
for the job from young to old and
eventually we found felix guy from
germany he made a very nice video good
jokes good quality and he has the exact
same van as matia feels like he's made
for this place
so here he is we don't know each other
at all but i guess we will become
friends over the year
hopefully also like his new videos
and another more practical update for
youtube comments since you always
recommend it we also bought some safety
gear
and another comment we actually often
get is that the music is bad so we had
some friends here from fresh plastic
coming together to make some music
they recorded a few songs and here's one
of them
[Music]
[Music]
and besides this we also updated our
main website we've added a bit more
information about projects and added
practical things like frequently asked
questions for instance whether we are a
cult
[Music]
we've also updated our ways to support
the big things you can donate like
supporting the renovation of our
workspace buy a tractor or just upgrade
our tools
we've updated our workforce section with
new positions so if you want to come and
help us here you can have a look we need
ecologists vegan chefs general help and
many more
this list will also grow and expand
throughout the whole year so keep an eye
on it
and last digital thing we also released
our research module in the community
platform here we will document ongoing
research things that are a bit more
in-depth and detailed than you show in a
youtube video
and this will also be the main place to
share suggestions and help us out if you
want to help remotely
have a look at it keep an eye on it and
the more people come here the more
research we'll do
and finally we've also got our paperwork
in place it was a bit messy last year
since we did many things privately we
just wanted to move forward so we're now
set up as a portuguese association
and it's mainly to keep track of our
administration and get a bank account
and stuff like that
so this is all the stuff we've been
doing in this period between season one
and now
how to get ready for the next season so
let me show you all the things and goals
you want to achieve for this year for
season 2.
all right so first on our list is this
small ruin last year we cleaned it up
because it was fully overgrown it's a
granite building with bricks on top
almost collapsing so first we're gonna
make an inventory of what's inside and
see the structural strength
the goal of this year is to make sure
the roof is closed the walls are thick
it's insulated and we can put a stove
inside because this will be our warm
place for next year winter so it's a
good deadline
after that this will become our guest
house where we can invite experts from
around the world to research a specific
topic in project camp
the money to renovate this one is
donated by a member in our discord so
thank you very much for that
so next we have our big ruin and this
building was actually not registered in
all the paperwork so the goal for this
year is to make sure we legalize it and
put it in the right paperwork so it's
all good to go
and besides that we also want to start
the design process so we uploaded a 3d
model of the space in the research
module online so you guys can download
it and share suggestions of what you
think the space should look like and
what should be inside so we can design
it all together and that would also be
the goal of this year to make sure we
have a final design for this one all the
paperwork legal and then next year
hopefully we can start renovating
[Laughter]
oh damn
so next we also want to expand our
workspace area because currently all our
tools and material are stuffed into the
shipping container which is getting
quite small especially with more people
around
and we would like to expand that by
having more dry area and ideally also in
shipping containers so we can have for
instance a shipping container for our
woodworking materials
and but also for the gardening materials
like chainsaws and brush cutters
so this year we want to look into
what is legally allowed to do on the
land
to make sure that next year we can
expand our workspace area
and another big thing we want to do this
year is landscaping and we did it a
little bit by clearing up some areas for
instance the swamp over here which was
fully overgrown but we didn't really
intervene too much yet because we didn't
really have a plan and this year we want
to make sure we have that five to ten
year holistic plan on how to treat the
land
so to think about which kind of trees do
we plant how do we retain the water do
we need to make terraces so if you're an
expert in this field
an ecologist looking into landscaping
have a look at the website to see how
you can help us out
and besides making this plan which you
want to have ready end of the year we
also want to do one big tree planting
action towards the end of the year when
it's a good time to plant and really
start to regenerate the land and taking
out those invasive trees and already
plant back a few new ones
yeah and in order to speed up our work
we need a lamborghini
now we don't really need a lamborghini
but we need a tractor and because we
have a lot of landscaping to do soil to
move
boots to chip
and trees to move around so landscaping
with a tractor would speed up the whole
process and you can help us out if you
go to support.projectcamp.com
to donate as a tractor
and another big clearing action we want
to do this here is to clean up this
creek so there's water flowing there and
we already opened it up a little bit
over here
but it's a lot of work a lot of bushes
there's bar wire in there from the
previous owner because they had a fence
so you can't really clean it with a
tractor so it's going to be a big manual
job with a lot of people
and we're probably gonna have some local
people helping out not sure yet how but
the goal is to have it clean end of the
year then we see this beautiful creek
flowing here all the way
and another goal for this rocky
landscape is to build a few yoga decks
here from boot
a deck where you can do yoga meditation
or just chill so you can come to peace
after all the work and have a nice look
on the beautiful valley
so those are all the goals and things
you want to achieve on the land this
year we also have a little bit of a site
goal which is the amount of people we
want to be here so last year on average
we were here with two people and this
year we want to be here with 10 because
we think that's what the infrastructure
can hold
it's going to be very diverse people
from vegan chef to ecologists to
construction workers if you want to help
out make sure to visit the website where
you can see all the tasks and you can
actually come here to join us and help
us complete the goals
if you want to stay on the other side of
the world we also have the research
module where you're going to document
all the processes and things going on so
you can follow it step by step
or just keep watching these videos every
week it's awesome helps a lot
and actually if you want to already see
next week's video it's going to be
online as well today for our patreon
supporters so if you support on patreon
you can already see that video and it
helps to support the project
anyway thanks for watching the video
super cool see you next week
you